this is the original building this is
the finai than five nights that bad is
it this is where the animatronics were
made this is the prequel prequel this is
pretty cool pretty good freaking people
[Music]
yeah I still have my weapons I don't see
how this might be scary I guess I could
be like human hands when I swipe oh yeah
this is a good place what something
whoops don't worry guys I'll get you
some Mountain Dew revive you here drink
the Mountain Dew well mount do ah
there's Mountain Dew over here guys Andy
what are you doing Ken push me on this
cart okay
yay done push you all look beautiful the
exact same that go first
we're still fighting as a Freddie's
we're just in disguise he's nice he's
cool about if he cool is the devil you
need to click this keyboard oh Jesus we
I think we need to pray to lord gaben
load
oh my god like a trick shot at me
crowbar yeah 360 I got codes
there's codes in a number pad okay I'm
gonna go in the box you guys read a
numbers to me go eight nine zero one
great $32.99 I work 10 500 million you
were oh the doors open you know that
you're fine
that was so intense wait wait ammo for
guns I don't have there's a key on the
radio okay looks way tight sewn twilight
zone music oh yeah protect me the kill
protect you don't know which way is out
all you know is you find the scary door
that's the scary door hey I got the key
Oh what key well
[Music]
our there's something here oh geez
[ __ ] a bike the barrel moved I swear
to god the barrel move the barrel moved
wait 71 way 2503 right 7 125 0 yes
Einstein would suck my ass Oh icky icky
icky icky oh oh oh oh wait this is a
Boston hello dead body kiss me kiss me
oh yeah oh yeah I will kiss that
[Music]